[Music]
greetings
class of 2024 transfer students eli
whitney students
and visiting international students
welcome to yale
i'm marvin chan dean of yale college and
on behalf of the offices of the
university
the faculty the heads and deans of the
residential colleges
and the deans and staff members of the
yale college dean's office
i am so pleased to be with you today
family members and friends who are
joining us we extend our warm welcome to
you
and we thank you for everything you have
done to guide these young adults
in my role as dean one of my jobs is to
support president salovey's mission
for yale to be the research university
most committed to teaching and learning
what that means for you students is that
i am here to make sure that you get the
best
of what yale has to offer in the
classroom or outside of it
a good part of what you will learn here
will come from the faculty who will
teach you in the classes you take
while much will come from your peers and
colleagues
taken together these teachers of yours
will give you the liberal education that
is yale's hallmark
by the time you graduate you will have
furnished your mind in the broadest
possible sense
not by pursuing narrow specialized
fields of study
but instead by searching for new
knowledge new perspectives
new ways of looking at the world and by
adding your own
if you make good of this place you will
discover fields of knowledge that are
completely new to you
that you haven't even heard of and you
will open yourselves to them and learn
from them
now you're joining yale during a
uniquely challenging year for the
institution
and for the world the ongoing pandemic
requires us to curtail in-person group
gatherings and so most of your classes
and activities will be conducted online
starting with this opening assembly
still we can be grateful that in year
2020
modern technology equips us to overcome
this challenge better than ever
online we can stay connected
communicating our ideas
and sharing our passions as a
neuroscientist
i can assure you that to your brain
nestled inside of your head
sights and sounds from the world can be
as vivid online as they would be live
you don't need to be a neuroscientist to
understand that whether listening with
headphones
or from a person standing in front of
you the sound waves reaching your ears
are similar
and that whether the face you're seeing
is on a screen or across the classroom
the images you're seeing are comparable
if not for our agility with media
which brings us the world every day how
could the music film and broadcasting
industries be such a dominant form of
entertainment
in our daily lives
as you imagine the semester ahead think
about new ways
you will interact with the faculty and
other students just as your instructors
will be
also keep in mind that the faculty to
student ratio
is the best in yale's modern history
with more faculty teaching and
mentoring fewer students you are
entering yale
when its diverse faculty is the largest
it has ever been
and at a time when the number of
enrolled students is around 80 percent
its usual size one of the unanticipated
advantages
of starting your yell education now is
the increased attention you will receive
still with much of the semester now
online with fewer people around
you may be more easily distracted and if
you're like me
you might be guilty of occasional mind
wandering
in fact my own desire to be more focused
has led to a research
interest and attention throughout my
career my lab group
uses brain scanners to measure how
attentive a person is
and we explore ways to improve
concentration
so here let me make good use of this
online moment to help you be more
attentive
to the new ideas and opportunities that
await you at yale
i will now direct you to an on-screen
demonstration of how you can focus
better
to make distractions disappear
you see a background of flickering blue
dots with three stationary and salient
yellow dots forming a triangle
in the middle is a white plus sign and
i'll ask you to just stare at that
throughout this exercise
if you stay focused on the white plus
symbol without moving your eyes
you should notice that the yellow dots
will start disappearing
it may take a few seconds for this to
happen for you
especially if you're distracted right
now
the yellow dots will start disappearing
one or two at a time but for many of you
all three of them should disappear at
some point
this is a perceptual illusion called
motion-induced blindness
and at yale psychology professor brian
scholl studies it
there are many explanations for why
motion-induced blindness occurs
but for today's purpose just know that
you can willfully make distractions
disappear
with your newfound powers of attention
you not only can reduce distraction
you can use it to help you see new
perspectives and new ways of
understanding
you have all earned a place in this
community because of the promise that
you have shown
and what you will contribute to it and
you have so much to learn from each
other
when you get to know your colleagues
joining yale this year you will discover
that you come from
every possible walk of life bringing
with you every imaginable talent
every experience every world view
think about how to leverage your
different backgrounds views
talents and interests and by learning
how to see the world through each
other's eyes
it takes effort and attention to put
yourself in someone else's shoes
and it will be worth it to empathize
with others and to make
more informed decisions okay so now
let's turn to another demonstration to
use your mind and volition
to see things differently
you should see two dots moving on the
screen now do you see them moving
vertically
up and down in columns or do you see
them moving horizontally
oscillating between left and right in
rows
some of you will see them moving
vertically and others will see them
moving horizontally
this simple demonstration shows a
fundamental principle of psychology
we all experience the world differently
our perceptual interpretations
our memories and our thoughts are all
constructs of the mind
and they differ across people even when
they consider the same object
event or evidence
now i will ask you to see the dot
motions differently using your mindset
and attention if you see them moving
vertically
try to see them move along the
horizontal axis
and if you see them moving horizontally
try to see them move along the vertical
axis
it's hard but you can do it and if you
can't be assured that we still want you
at yale
but since we don't really have time now
here's a hint use your hand
to cover up the bottom row and this will
help you see the dots move horizontally
or use your hand to cover up the right
column and you will see the dots move
vertically
take your hand away and the motion
should stick
here's a final example of how you can
view one image two different ways
name out loud what you see
did you see a duck or did you see a
rabbit
can you see it both ways
your hand won't help here but the ducks
bill forms the rabbit ears
and the rabbit's nose is the back of the
duck's head
now look at the cartoon on the screen
two armies face each other
and for the army on the bottom find the
general at the front of it
urging his troops with his sword
there can be no peace until they
renounce their rabbit god and accept our
duck god
how can we help everyone understand that
they are serving the same flag
yale will expose you to views different
from your own and when it does
you can start by finding common ground
with people when you don't agree with
them
as yalies as our newest members of
bulldog nation
you are all under one flag with the
sophomores juniors and seniors
the alumni faculty and staff and with
each other
you have common ground an immediate
shared bond
that goes deep to the intellectual
curiosity
and the commitment to community that
have brought you all here
you have just arrived at a place that
values difference and
actively seeks it out it is how
professors and students find and test
knowledge
and it is how the university equips its
students that's you
to become leaders and citizens of the
world
but here the value of seeking difference
is even more than that
here it is taken as an article of faith
it is the coin of the realm
it is one of the bedrock principles that
governs us in and out of the classroom
let me assume that you have come here
not only to find knowledge
but also to learn how to live lives of
consequence
if that is true you have come to the
right place as you take your first steps
then
you will need to become comfortable with
difference not just to accept it
or tolerate it but to insist on it you
will find guides everywhere in the
classes you take
the activities you join and most of all
from the people joining you right now
your peers and classmates
all of them are part of the liberal arts
education that awaits you
your life at yale has started and as it
does here's what i hope you will do
if you are a duck person go find those
rabbit people and find common ground
with them
if you are studying lots of duck courses
go find the rabbit courses and see what
they can teach you
and when you find yourself rallying
around a duck flag take a good hard look
at that rabbit flag
across the field and the people rallying
around it and remember that you are all
yelis
members of the class of 2024 transfer
students eli whitney students visiting
international students
you belong to yale and yale belongs to
you welcome